and then Toon's point about the security
concerns I mean I think let's see how
much just in 10 15 years they really
dominate the EV market right I mean it
is technically possible for an electric
vehicle to be switched off by a
manufacturer remotely right so let's say
2third of British cars on Eves on the
roads are Chinese in 20 years if they
all on mass shut down clearly that's a
security risk but there are so many
other ifs involved in that could the
Chinese company will it will it really
do that considering that would be pretty
much suicide for that company to be kind
of killing its customers uh will the
Chinese Communist Party really demand
that of a company um all of these
different things I think there are a lot
of ifs here but when we talk about
National Security in this kind of
fevered era that we're in at the moment
it's a lot of about as about what is the
potential for something to go wrong what
is the potential for something to happen
and you know it's technically possible
but will it really happen and that's the
that's the analysis that you know policy
makers have to make